[Music]
attention all scientists as an inclusive
equal opportunity employer
the EU is looking for highly talented
scientific research specialists in the
following fields quantitative and
qualitative policy impact assessment and
evaluation data science applications
modeling for policy development of space
telecommunication and remote sensing
applications scientific knowledge
management and communication and nuclear
research and decommissioning recruited
specialists will mainly be active in the
European Commission's joint research
center
you'll be working together at the core
of the Union science and technology hub
supporting development and monitoring of
EU pulses to apply you must have a
university degree of at least three or
four years in a relevant scientific
domain followed by at least six or seven
years professional experience
respectively knowledge of at least two
official EU languages is also required
are you suited for the job for more
information on specific requirements
please visit scientists dot EU - careers
dot EU shaping Europe together